let's take a look at this chart based on
survey data from the pew research center
researchers asked us adults in early
2020 which issues they think should be
top priorities for the president and
congress the top two issues were the
economy
and the environment now as we compare
that to other years you can see that
these two policy issues haven't always
been top of mind although the economy
has ranked first since 2002 until
recently jobs were second the
environment was last place for several
years and climate change didn't even
make the list until 2015. so what's
going on here
questions like these help political
scientists measure the policy mood of
the public people's preferences toward
policy choices
as you can see policy mood changes over
time in response to problems and issues
that arise
for example in 2009 as a response to the
economic crash surveyed adults responded
that jobs should be a top priority but
in 2020 after a period of economic
recovery and low unemployment jobs had
fallen as a main concern and new issues
had taken its place climate change has
become a major concern for many people
which wasn't even a term that people
knew a few decades ago conversely a poll
like this taken in 1980 might have shown
containing communism as a main concern
but since the fall of the soviet union
that has dropped off the list
these measures of policy mood help
politicians and political parties craft
their policy agendas in order to attract
voters and serve their constituents but
if so many people think that the economy
should be a major priority why don't
voters all just agree on a course of
action here's where ideological
differences come into play political
scientists sometimes divide policy
issues into position issues and valence
issues
position issues are issues that divide
voters
like abortion or gun control where there
isn't much room for overlapping opinions
valence issues are issues that most
voters will agree with like our
communities should be free of crime or
we should care for the elderly these are
high level values that cut across
partisan lines but the parties might
differ on how to achieve those outcomes
for example although both democrats and
republicans might want to reduce drug
use republicans might argue that tougher
drug laws are most likely to achieve
that goal while democrats might argue
that prevention and education programs
would be more effective so policy mood
tells us what the public thinks is most
important at any given time but
differing ideological beliefs about how
best to achieve those priorities lead to
different approaches on the left and the
right